[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
so for those who don't know have no clue
tell the realm
what element is what's the premise
so the premise development is where
uh the world is kind of enshameless in
terms of the climate and um
in disarray
and uh you're sent to this world called
el amithia it looks cool
pre-alpha y'all you're getting a
disclaimer
it's early dessert
i think what we're kind of finding
so right now we've got yeah they're just
having enough pretty much all the
systems in there's one
so you'll be able to
find imagine the world and sneak up on
them and then they'll go in your
inventory you'll be able to switch
themselves
so throughout the world you'll be able
to find different magic spells
different bosses will drop different
elements
and um and different gear
so we just put the quest system in so
now
[Music]
we have the map here so this is
just
the nature biome and it's not even all
of it so it's about one
tenth of the match so this is one tenth
of one bite
no one tenth of the time of the entire
battle but this is the damage half of
the knife got it okay
so right now uh yeah so that's what we
have about so for the quest
they show up here and then you can track
them
and then they'll be able to so they show
up on your
map now
and also on your yeah
oh we got the glider okay
yeah so i was kind of playing first of
all with my kids and i said
it would be cool if you had this but
multiplayer this is going to be local
split screen as
yeah seems well
be a very controversial thing these days
including
games
very impressively
i'm being messy i apologize but um oh
wow so we got we got a horse back riding
so again you're talking local squishy
but let
[Music]
so essentially like the story is
this is naya
and they have their own progression
gotcha okay fair enough fair enough so
they can profit and come up yeah so this
person here will be going to be some
more quest
each village will have its own
different blacksmiths who you can
craft out here from
so these are all custom
um
custom models that we had like
concepted
so again these statistics here so it's
something like a general health what are
we here doing here yeah so right now so
this is your hour so uh sir this is your
house so this will go up depending on if
you get uh additional uh bonuses to your
health um this is your armor so if i
take off that for example like it goes
down
so um this is your attack
[Music]
so this is a legendary item
so it's a lot higher yes in terms of its
staff one thing i could appreciate as a
destiny fan oh my gosh
oh my god
i can tell the inspiration i'm like
i love it though so i'm trying to keep
it where you can so now you have that
rare number so what you can do
is
upgrade that so you don't have to have
to have multiple sets you know you can
upgrade i can upgrade that i think you
can upgrade it
too much
and that was the other thing i wanted to
mention is the softening also kind of
inspired by
destiny
so
you can add perks
you know you can add like
not only different
resistances and stuff but it could be
like a boost of speed
it could be uh
you gain health on kills
water power that just kind of started
out yeah
those are magic abilities that
you'll gain so
they also have an elemental
elemental
like resistance and damage because
these guys are nice
these guys are nice face so it won't
have too much of an effect on that right
and also there's a parry oh okay so this
guy's attacking me
and she dropped some ice arrows nice
so this guy here like he's attacking me
i should be able to ferry
[Music]
years right now and we're looking to
release
the end of 2020 so hopefully you're
trying to get it soon there might be a
playable demo before that
and
what platforms we looking at
uh
first it's gonna be on steam and then
we're going to be on all functions oh
sorry
you already have my attention you can
talk a breath of the wild with a little
bit of destiny customization
some local product co-op action with
your friends we're going to keep our
eyes on it man our law
absolute pleasure brother thank you so
much really cool i opp in the building
has an element y'all
[Music]